il enseigne propose voyage sans
passeport
docteur percheron puisque nous avons le
plaisir vous voyagez un nouveau avec
vous je vais vous demander un petit
conseil à votre avis à votre avis de
grand voyageur de quelle façon et par
quel bout faut-il aborder la grèce mais
il faut aborder la grèce par mr voyant
n'y a qu'à regarder la configuration
géographique
le découpage déco le nombre d' idiot on
comprend que la grèce est un pays
essentiellement maritime
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui lui a permis de
vous procédez à 30 échanges de recevoir
tant de civilisations et d'aller à ce
qu'elle est et à rayonner également
voilà maintenant dans un si petit
village toul en eux mêmes les rues même
les marches parfaire son lent chez à la
chaux et à béziers au qui sont en face
de nous qui sont les stations balnéaires
oui voilà le type même de ces nuages de
l'attique des ports de la grèce ou du
péloponnèse avec ses clochers à mykonos
il ya je crois 300 églises
oui presque une église par jour on peut
aller différement
et voilà le atelier voilà quelque chose
que je voulais vous montrer en passant
mais nous allons la revoir c'est leur
rocher du bourreau un oppidum pluie et
dans le péloponnèse a été une des
capitales
la première capitale d'ailleurs après la
proclamation d'indépendance de la grèce
au début du 19e siècle
et là le bourreau tenez ces assises et
on l'avait mis dans cette île non pas
pour l'enfermer mais pour le protéger
d'une certaine vindicte qui pouvaient
s'exercer sur lui
essai transformé maintenant on hôtel
absolument charmant un peu monacale le
chambre me sens très nue mais on a vue
sur la mer et envoie la coface cas
connaissant je crois que là bas ce sont
seul véhicule de l'emploi sont échaudés
visite est un pro non non on voit les
arts ah oui à lézat 17 ex andré jallet
par les voitures en voilà une qui
viennent passer mais c'est peut-être
maintenant trouver le nom
veilhan notre un peu parce que il ya
relativement peu d'eau si il ya de très
belles routes de tourisme magnifique ce
mot qu'elles ne sont pas assez nombreux
et vous avez 100 c'est un animal très
turbulent greffier toujours pensé qu'il
était un peu machine est cher et
pourquoi pas en amoureux du monde des
pandas à 25 % avec une aisance étonnante
c'est courageux il pourra jouer on le
charge et l'est toujours de bonne humeur
c'est merveilleux et l'odeur ces odeurs
balsamique ses senteurs n'y a qu'en
grèce qu'on sent qu'on sent la nature
que l'odorat est satisfait à ce point
conick nous voilà cnossos en crète
et il ya trois capital successives qui
ont été pendant deux mille cent ans
édifié sur ces parents là et ces
colonnes sont rondes et d'un rouge
pierre péan rouge pour des liens et il
est un tueur que vous voyez c'est facile
sont admirablement conservé de lait par
exemple le prince à la pelure il est
rouge pour des gains bleu et blanc c'est
admirable que ses choix
eh bien ce sont déjà déshabillé des
chirac
tous deux n'ont eux mêmes de 1500 ans
verra blement décor et shine allure
extraordinaire de nouveau la mer vous
avez de nouveau la mer est toujours là
mère et jamais elle n'y est lassante
nous allons je crois faire maintenant le
tour de la can voilà de ces bateaux
description s'arrête au pied de petit
monastère de vie lui remonte par des
escaliers ou des les chemins escarpés
que seuls les arbres à papillons et des
traces de la l'occupation turque
c'était un des derniers bastions et la
butte de la crêpe ans d'indépendance et
une défausse et fuse écrit que l'on
puisse imaginer c'est vraiment de tout
beauté ya eu des livres drake
extraordinaire là dessus c'est très
saisissant voilà bah ya des traces
encore de balles sur les murs qui n'a
rien à huy vieille de 80 ans
le temps n'efface pas tout en écoutant
rien
regardez comme c'est escarpé a regardé
ce découpage ce découpage de la côte
et qu'est ce que c'est qu'une blanche 1
cd les brisants et weeds un essai petit
village qui se tapissent qui ne vivent
que par la mer voyez vous on ne peut
presque pas gagné l'arrière pays bas
leur vie est essentiellement mari est ce
qu il fait très chaud à partir de juin
c'est sévère qu'est ce que vous appelez
césaire à cdu celui 30 qui veut 6,38 à
le roman le haut salaire je n'ai pas ça
n'a plus de limites du rock se dote du
on aperçoit des ruines d'efforts turc 40
ou même défendent énormément laureline
il avait défendu contre les pirates
d'abord contre les grecs ensuite les
grecs demandent ce qu'ils appelaient le
continent de mer en mer de coin de mer
en mer car dès qu'on s'est découpé voilà
les montagnes
voyez bien je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
il faut être arrivées par mer mais il
faut arriver aussi par l'avion garde
l'avion vous donne en plan ce découpage
de la crise est étonnant c'est une très
belle image
ces travaux un an ce drainage à
l'intérieur par ses valets et qui amène
jusqu'à la mer était permettent de faire
venir des produits de l'intérieur ces
salaires - désolé c - désolé que ça en a
l'air
boeing le l'altitude nous et fasse un
petit peu le relief ces curieuses l'âge
on dirait une peinture et bien ce c'est
la culture en terrasses et je n'ai vu
qu'à java une pareille densité de ses
terrasses des chenaux d'écueils toujours
toujours la mer
à l'aller moulin ceux ci se sont une
moule un de robes et c'est à peu près
sept ans drôle un peu sur la droite qui
était le colosse de rhodes le fameux
colosse en bronze qui est question que
un bateau pouvait passer entre ses
jambes écartées voilà les remparts qui
avait construit les chevaliers de saint
sépulcre et le royaume au franc qui
s'était qu'alliance eut tendresse
avaient fortifié absolument d'excusés
c'est à rhodes qui à cette fameuse à
l'aider et langues
la rue des langues il y à la maison de
france mais en italie la maison de
magne la maison de grande bretagne qui
date du 15ème siècle c'est libéraux saïd
et bougainville et de jasmin cellulaire
une serre avis quelle est la meilleure
saison à peu près en ce moment voyez
vous depuis le printemps le printemps le
printemps il risque voilà un intérieur
de
chaque tome et ronald qui a été restauré
par les italiens qui n'ont vraiment pas
trop massaka ils n'ont pas trop abîmer
non parade passé mais il faut le
reconnaître du goût tout de même oui et
alors les moulins à six branches qui
sont tellement de caractéristiques des
îles de la grèce regardez celle des
hommes sio est par nature mais c'est un
brin vieux turquerie n'est ce pas
raismes allemand ne ment c'est une
occupation
d'ailleurs ça sent la turquie c'est oui
le gère oui ça sent les turcs et 500 aux
idées car il ya cette odeur d'huile et
de beignets qui caractérise istanbul
ah oui mons là c'est au reste de tentes
tout blanc qui se découpe sur mer
voilà
je vis de cause cela vous savez qu'à
cause il y avait le temple d'hippocrate
c'était la grande école de médecine et
il ya même un endroit où
on pourra quand même donné son
enseignement alors esculape on y avait
délié exactement comment on allait
gagner un coq et c'était une école de
médecine avec sale d'anatomie salle de
dissection extrêmement complexe prend
des bains au cinécure hâtif voilà voilà
la chambre je vous parle est ouvert aux
ânes bien aimé ils ont l'air vivant il
ya beaucoup de banques comme vous le
voyez et en l'utilisant l'utilisent
moderne c'est pas très beau c'est ces
pylônes détruits mais ce qu'il ya de la
difficulté pour deux pour l'eau pour
trouver de l'eau oui elle est assez
profondément enfouis dans le sol
elle est fraîche aller d'une fraîcheur
c'est un avantage ça et voilà les
oranges et citrons
voilà le sens vu de patmos nous sommes à
patmos vous savez qu à patmos saint jean
a écrit l'apocalypse ou plutôt à biper
l'apocalypse
oubliée je suis ravi de le ré apprendre
il avait 90 ans 91 ans était un
vieillard terrible atrabilaire pas du
tout saint jean bouclet qui a l'air de
premier communiant quand me représente
laisse songeur y ait du continent merci
infiniment docteur percheron de tant de
savoir
ivan chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours du docteur percheron et
de solange péters montage pierre rey
sont à nick v discrit nathalie de muret
illustration sonore de nice blazer